hooray you're done implementing
wireframes for the apt now comes the
visual polish part where we tweak the
styles and the views to make the appt
look awesome here are the visual mocks
for what the app should look like when
we're done if you work with the designer
they should also give you red lines red
line specify everything from sizes font
styles colors spacing etc this should
help you achieve pixel perfect layouts
that match the visual mocks how do we
come up with these values well we use
the Android design guide which has
information on metrics and grids and we
adapted them to fit our acts needs you
can click on the link for more info